I was 20, but it was the first time I'd ever been to Boston. Kirstie Paul and another student from England had just arrived at Logan Airport. They were about to embark on a new adventure, living in a new city, working with a very important Harvard professor. We stepped off the plane, still a little bit jack lad, very disorientated, going up to this prestigious academic institute that's famous all over the world. Kirstie could think of only one thing to keep her nervousness in check. She had corresponded with a graduate student, Maureen Brinkworth,
我当时20岁，但那是我第一次去波士顿。克斯蒂·保罗（Kirstie Paul）和来自英格兰的另一名学生刚刚抵达洛根机场。她们即将开启一段新的冒险，在一个新的城市生活，与一位非常重要的哈佛教授共事。我们走下飞机，脑子还有点晕乎乎的，方向感全无，即将走进这个闻名全球的顶尖学术机构。克斯蒂能想到的唯一一件事，就是克制住自己的紧张情绪。她之前和一位名叫莫琳·布林克沃思（Maureen Brinkworth）的研究生有过书信往来，
and Maureen was to be her supervisor and her mentor. Maureen was also going to be Kirstie's lifeline, someone who would help her navigate not just the halls of Harvard, but the streets of Boston. So we stumbled to the place where she said she was going to be. So she said she would be in Harvard Square opposite a certain restaurant. And so we find it and then we see her and we're just so nervous, but she just, Maureen just had this massive big smile and she just kind of puts you at ease straight away.
而且莫琳将成为她的主管和导师。莫琳还将成为克斯蒂的救星，一个不仅能帮她熟悉哈佛校园，还能帮她了解波士顿街道的人。于是我们跌跌撞撞地找到了她所说的地方。她说她会在哈佛广场某家餐厅的对面等我们。我们找到了那个地方，然后看到了她，心里紧张极了，但莫琳脸上带着灿烂的笑容，一下子就让我们放松了下来。
And she was like, I'm so excited to meet you. You know, welcome. And then she took us around. And with that, the ice was broken. Over the next few months, Maureen became more than a mentor to Kirstie. She became her friend. But there was something else that was interesting here. This kind of friendship between student and teacher
她表现得非常高兴能见到我们，并说：“欢迎你们。”接着她就带我们四处逛了逛。就这样，陌生感烟消云散了。在接下来的几个月里，莫琳对克斯蒂而言不仅是一位导师，更成了她的朋友。但这里还有另一个有趣的地方。学生和老师之间的这种友谊，
was also the subject of the research that Kirstie and Maureen were conducting along with Harvard Professor Hunter Gelbach. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. In this episode, we're going to talk about the relationships between students and mentors. The bond that Maureen and Kirstie developed made a huge difference in Kirstie's life. Now, I can relate to this. I've had wonderful mentors and teachers, and I know what a difference a great teacher can make. But what about all those students and teachers who don't have that connection?
也是克斯蒂和莫琳与哈佛教授亨特·格尔巴赫（Hunter Gelbach）共同开展的研究课题。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。在本期节目中，我们将探讨学生与导师之间的关系。莫琳和克斯蒂建立的深厚情谊对克斯蒂的人生产生了巨大的影响。对此，我深有同感。我曾遇到过非常优秀的导师和老师，我知道一位伟大的老师能带来多大的改变。但是，那些没有建立起这种联系的学生和老师又该怎么办呢？
Today, we're going to tell you about new research that shows that when you don't have that natural spark of chemistry, close relationships between teachers and students can be engineered. And when you do this, it has an incredible positive effect. Stay with us to find out what Maureen, Hunter and Curstie learn together. One lovely autumn day, I was biking along with my daughter and a friend of hers in the bike trailer. And my wife and I had had these sort of ongoing conversations, my daughter's about three at this point, wondering, you know, what actually goes into friendship at age three?
今天，我们将向大家介绍一项新研究，该研究表明：当你和老师之间没有那种自然的化学反应时，老师和学生之间的紧密关系其实是可以人为构建的。当你这样做时，会产生令人难以置信的积极效果。请继续收听，了解莫琳、亨特和克斯蒂共同学到了什么。在一个美丽的秋日，我骑着自行车带着女儿和她的小朋友（坐在自行车拖斗里）。我和妻子之前一直在断断续续地讨论一个问题——我女儿当时大概三岁——我们在想，三岁时的友谊究竟是由什么构成的呢？
Why has my daughter taken a particular shine to this girl as opposed to some other kid in the class? That's Hunter Gelbach, Maureen and Kirstie's professor at the Harvard Graduate School of Education. And as I'm biking along, I feel like I have figured out the answer to this question because I hear the following conversation. So my daughter says, I like ice cream. The friend says, I like ice cream. My daughter says, I like blueberries. The friend says, me too. I like chocolate ice cream. You can kind of see where this is going. I like chocolate ice cream too.
为什么我女儿偏偏对这个小女孩情有独钟，而不是班上的其他孩子？说话的是亨特·格尔巴赫，莫琳和克斯蒂在哈佛大学教育学院的教授。正当我骑着车时，我觉得自己似乎找到了这个问题的答案，因为我听到了以下这段对话。我女儿说：“我喜欢冰激凌。”那个小朋友说：“我也喜欢冰激凌。”我女儿说：“我喜欢蓝莓。”那个朋友说：“我也是。我喜欢巧克力冰激凌。”你大概能猜到接下来会怎么发展。我也喜欢巧克力冰激凌。
The friend at this point said, I have a dog. I like my dog. Now it actually gets sort of interesting. So ever since age two, my daughter's been petrified of dogs since there was this little pug that jumped up on her and knocked her over.
那个小朋友这时候说：“我有一只狗。我喜欢我的狗。”接下来的对话变得有点意思了。原来，自我女儿两岁起，她就对狗产生了极大的恐惧，因为曾有一只小哈巴狗扑到她身上把她撞倒过。
So my daughter kind of shifts the category from dog to pets, and so she replies, I have a pet frog, I like my frog. The friend continues, I don't like pizza, I don't like pizza. So now she's just playing line. The friend says,
于是我女儿把话题从“狗”扩大到了“宠物”，她回答说：“我有一只宠物青蛙，我喜欢我的青蛙。”那个小朋友接着说：“我不喜欢披萨，我不喜欢披萨。”现在她只是在顺着对方的话说。那个朋友说：
I don't like blueberries, I don't like blueberries anymore either. So anyway the point being as I'm huffing and puffing on the bike, it seems like what goes into friendships or relationships, and obviously I'm oversimplifying a little bit, is that they have stuff in common, so they go through all these crazy machinations to establish that they are similar to each other in all these, you know, what would seem like kind of superficial ways. Hunter realized that the conversation he had overheard had bigger implications than just friendships between three or all.
“我不喜欢蓝莓，我也不喜欢蓝莓了。”总之，我想表达的是，当我气喘吁吁地骑着自行车时，我发现友谊或人际关系的建立——当然我有点过度简化了——在于他们有共同点，所以他们会经历各种奇怪的心理博弈，来证明彼此在这些看似非常肤浅的方面是相似的。亨特意识到，他无意中听到的这段对话其实有着比三个或所有孩子之间的友谊更深远的意义。
Yeah, so let's back up a little bit. So I had had a sort of primary research interest for a long, long time in looking at social perspective taking. So how do teachers and students in particular kind of figure out what each other is thinking and feeling. And so I had a graduate student who was someone I worked with very closely for a long, long time, or Ian Brinkworth, who was really interested in teacher student relationships. And so this seemed like a really natural combination to look
嗯，那我们稍微回溯一下。长期以来，我的主要研究兴趣之一一直是社交视角采择。也就是说，老师和学生特别是如何揣摩对方的想法和感受的。我曾有一位研究生，我和她非常紧密地合作了很长时间，也就是莫琳·布林克沃思，她对师生关系非常感兴趣。因此，研究我们如何进行日常的“读心术”，学生和老师在课堂上是如何做到这一点的，以及他们的关系有多好，这看起来是一个非常自然结合的研究方向。为了他心中的实验，亨特为九年级班级的学生和教师制作了一份问卷。这份问卷试图找出老师和学生之间的共同点。研究人员在寻找各种各样的联系。他们提出了各种问题，
at this sort of how do we do this everyday mind reading and how our students and teachers doing this with each other in the classroom and how good are their relationships. For the experiment he had in mind Hunter created a survey for students and teachers of a ninth grade class. The questionnaire attempted to pinpoint things that teachers and students had in common. The researchers were looking for all kinds of connections. They asked a range of questions. Classroom relevant stuff to outside the classroom stuff, personal to subject matter related sorts of things, several of them kind of speak to people's values. So it was a pretty broad cross section. The researchers selectively shared examples
从课堂相关的内容到课外的内容，从个人爱好到学科相关的话题，其中有几个触及了人们的价值观。所以这是一个相当广泛的横断面。研究人员有选择地向老师和学生分享了一些例子，
with the teachers and students that suggested they both had things in common. So a teacher who felt she had nothing in common with a student might discover they both had the same sense of humor. Or a student who felt like his teacher was from Mars might discover they both liked football. When Hunter examined the scores of students who had been induced to see that they had things
表明他们双方有共同之处。因此，一个觉得自己和一个学生没有任何共同点的老师可能会发现，他们俩有着相同的幽默感。或者一个觉得老师来自火星的学生可能会发现，他们俩都喜欢橄榄球。当亨特检查那些被引导发现自己与老师有共同点的学生的成绩时，
in common with their teachers, he found something astonishing. The relationships between teachers and students got stronger, and as they did, students, especially minorities, suddenly started to perform better in class. Then when we look at academic achievement with respect to these black and Latino students, what we find is that when they're in the treatment group, their grades go up by about 0.4 of a letter grade, which translates into over 60% plus reduction in the achievement gap at the school.
他发现了一件令人惊奇的事。师生关系变得更加融洽了，随之而来的是，学生们（尤其是少数族裔学生）在课堂上的表现突然开始变好了。接着，当我们考察这些黑人和拉丁裔学生的学业成绩时，我们发现，当他们处于实验组时，他们的成绩提高了大约0.4个字母等级，这意味着该校的成绩差距缩小了60%以上。
That's right, this simple intervention closed 60% of the achievement gap. Educators have been struggling for decades to find ways to close this gap because it's one of the achievement gap. Educators have been struggling for decades to find ways to close this gap because it's one of the most persistent and disturbing disparities in American education. Now, I don't want to imply that this one intervention can fix the whole problem. Hunter's experiment is going to have to be replicated at other schools, with other students and other teachers, but I think the idea is really promising. It's inexpensive, it's easy, and it builds on top of a mountain of other research that finds strong relationships between students and teachers make a difference.
没错，这个简单的干预措施缩小了60%的成绩差距。几十年来，教育工作者一直在努力寻找缩小这种差距的方法，因为这是美国教育中最顽固、最令人不安的不平等现象之一。现在，我并不是暗示这单一的干预措施就能解决所有问题。亨特的实验还需要在其他学校、与其他学生和老师一起进行复制，但我认为这个想法真的很有前景。它成本低、操作简单，并且建立在大量其他研究的基础之上——这些研究发现，学生和老师之间紧密的联系能带来改变。
I asked Hunter why black and Latinos might benefit the most from this kind of intervention. So it's a hugely important question. I think my best guess at this point is that when teachers, and you know, for the most part these are white European American teachers, they walk into the classroom, they may not perceive that they would necessarily have much in common with the black and Latino students. You know, that may have implications for how they then end up teaching in the classroom, but as soon as we give them this little anchor and say, hey, you know what, you guys have this in common or you really feel similarly around this,
我问亨特，为什么黑人和拉丁裔学生可能会从这种干预中获益最多。这是一个非常重要的问题。我想我目前的最好猜测是，当老师们——你知道，绝大多数是白人欧裔美国教师——走进教室时，他们可能不会觉得自己和黑人和拉丁裔学生有多少共同点。你知道，这可能会对他们最终在课堂上的教学方式产生影响，但只要我们给他们这个小小的“锚”，告诉他们：“嘿，你知道吗，你们有这个共同点，或者你们在这方面的看法真的很相似，
you share these values, it gives them a hook or an entry point to connect with these students in a productive way as they might have figured out or done on their own with the white and Asian students. There was one twist in the research that Hunter had not anticipated. Students clearly did better academically when their relationships with teachers were strengthened, but when Hunter asked students about whether those relationships were stronger, the students mostly shrugged. And, you know, I'll be honest, I was kind of annoyed that the students didn't feel closer to their teachers as the result of, you know, this intervention that I had put together just for them.
你们分享这些价值观，”这就为他们提供了一个切入点或桥梁，让他们能够以一种富有成效的方式与这些学生建立联系，就像他们本可以凭借一己之力与白人和亚裔学生建立联系那样。这项研究中还有一个亨特没有预料到的转折。当师生关系得到加强时，学生的学业表现明显变好了，但当亨特问及学生这些关系是否变得更紧密时，学生们大多耸耸肩表示不知情。说实话，我当时有点恼火，因为学生们并没有因为我专门为他们设计的干预措施而觉得与老师更亲近。
In many ways, it was almost as if strengthening the relationships made a bigger difference to teachers than a DITTA students. And I think, you know, with the sort of connections between teachers and students, there's a default to thinking about how important this is for the students and what they get out of it. But for the teachers or the mentors, you know, I think there's a lot in it too. And I think one of the biggest things I got from my relationship with Maureen. Remember Maureen? That's the woman we told you about earlier in this episode. She helped Hunter conceive the project. She helped design the questionnaires for the ninth grade students, and the bond she formed with Hunter and with new research assistants such as Kirstie
在很多方面，加强关系对老师产生的影响甚至比对学生产生的影响还要大。而且我认为，在老师和学生之间的这种联系中，人们往往习惯于去思考这对学生有多重要、他们能从中收获什么。但对于老师或导师来说，我认为他们同样获益匪浅。我认为我从与莫琳的关系中获得的最大收获之一……还记得莫琳吗？就是我们在本期节目早些时候向大家介绍的那位女性。她帮助亨特构思了这个项目，她协助设计了针对九年级学生的问卷，她与亨特以及像克斯蒂·保罗这样的新研究助理建立的深厚情谊，为整个项目的方向提供了指引。
Paul informed the entire direction of the project. But as the research was wrapping up and getting ready to be published, Maureen's own relationship with the entire research team was changing because of a personal tragedy that was unfolding in her own life. I believe it was shortly after her 30th birthday that she got the initial cancer diagnosis. Hunter says that Maureen's strength in the face of this tragedy had a profound effect on him. You know, the level of optimism that she maintained was just, you know, something that I think I will forever strive to emulate and to keep in perspective that when things are going that poorly in life, you can make a really big difference to other people through your attitude. I send her a letter. That's Kostya again, the student who Maureen mentored.
但正当研究接近尾声、准备发表时，莫琳与整个研究团队的关系却发生了变化，因为她的生活发生了一场个人悲剧。我记得大约在她30岁生日后不久，她被初次诊断出患有癌症。亨特说，莫琳面对这场悲剧时表现出的坚强对他产生了深远的影响。你知道，她一直保持的那种乐观态度，真的……我想我会永远努力去效仿，并以此时刻提醒自己：当生活陷入绝境时，你可以通过自己的态度对他人产生非常大的影响。我给她写了一封信。这是克斯蒂再次发言，也就是莫琳指导过的那个学生。
I just kind of wrote down every good memory I have of her and just everything that made me smile about her and how I was so thankful to have had her in my life. Maureen made a significant and positive impact on the research, on the students she mentored, and on her teacher. What I found very powerful is that Maureen's story and her relationship with Hunter and Kirstie and the research they conducted with the ninth grade students all point to the same thing. The relationship between students and teachers is not incidental to how education works, it's central. We were sad to learn that Maureen died in 2014.
我把关于她的所有美好记忆、所有能让我对她微笑的事情，以及我多么庆幸生命中有她的存在，全都写了下来。莫琳对这项研究、对她指导的学生以及对她的老师都产生了重大而积极的影响。我发现非常有力量的一点是，莫琳的故事、她与亨特和克斯蒂的关系，以及他们与九年级学生共同开展的研究，都指向了同一件事：师生关系并不是教育运作中的附加品，而是核心。得知莫琳于2014年去世的消息，我们感到非常难过。
She passed away, just as the research she worked on with Hunter and Cursty was being published. Coming up, we're going to change gears. I'm going to place top-what science with Daniel Pink. We look at more research into how relationships between students and teachers can affect education. Back in just a moment. Back now for another round of stopwatch science, I'm Shankar Vaitanthin. And I'm Daniel Pink. Dan is our stopwatch science correspondent. He's also the author of several books about human behavior. On stopwatch science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting
她与亨特和克斯蒂共同开展的研究才刚发表，她就离世了。接下来，我们要转换话题了。我将与丹尼尔·平克（Daniel Pink）一起进行“秒表科学”（Stopwatch Science）环节。我们将探讨更多关于师生关系如何影响教育的研究。稍后回来。欢迎回到又一期的“秒表科学”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我是丹尼尔·平克。丹是我们的“秒表科学”记者。他也是多本关于人类行为畅销书的作者。在“秒表科学”节目中，我和丹会给对方60秒的时间来总结社会科学研究中的有趣观点。
ideas from social science research. I run a stopwatch as Dan speaks and here's the buzzer Dan's going to hear if he hits up against his deadline. Okay. Alright, that's a sign of applause because Dan Pink never hits up against his deadline. Dan, what's the sound of my buzzer? You're going to hear a little throwback sound. It's kind of like a 1970s clock radio buzzer. Take a listen. All right, I love it. As we've just heard, the ties between teachers and students and the
在丹发言时我会计时，如果丹超时了，他就会听到蜂鸣器响。好的。好的，这是掌声，因为丹·平克从不超时。丹，我的蜂鸣器是什么声音？你会听到一个复古的声音。有点像20世纪70年代的钟控收音机蜂鸣器。听听看。好的，我很喜欢。正如我们刚才所听到的，老师和学生之间的纽带，以及
beliefs that teachers and students have about one another can make a big difference in the classroom. On today's edition of Stopwatch Science, we stick with this theme with ideas related to the effects that teachers have on students. Down if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now. Well, this is a 2014 study that you actually talked about a while back on Morning Edition Shockard. It comes from Friend of the Show Katie Milkman. And here's what she did. She looked at 6,500 professors in 89 disciplines.
老师和学生对彼此的信念，可以在课堂上产生巨大的影响。在今天的“秒表科学”节目中，我们继续围绕这个主题，探讨老师对学生产生影响的相关观点。丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。这是一个2014年的研究，尚卡尔，你前段时间在《早间版》（Morning Edition）节目中其实也讨论过。它来自我们节目的老朋友凯蒂·米尔克曼（Katie Milkman）。她是这么做的：她调查了89个学科的6500名教授。
She sent emails to these professors from fictitious students asking, can I meet with you to discuss research opportunities? Now, the student names were randomly assigned, so half were men and half were women, and they also signaled ethnicity and race. So some of the students had signaled I'm African American, Hispanic, Indian, Chinese. Did that make a difference in whether the professor responded? And unfortunately, it did. Surprise, surprise, white males got way more responses.
她用虚构的学生的身份给这些教授发邮件，问道：“我能和你见面讨论一下研究机会吗？”学生的姓名是随机分配的，一半是男性，一半是女性，同时这些名字也暗示了其族裔和种族。因此，有些学生的名字暗示“我是非裔美国人、西班牙裔、印度人、中国人”。这会影响教授的回应吗？不幸的是，确实会。意料之中，白人男性收到了多得多的回复。
But here's the interesting thing. It was actually more likely to happen at private institutions and public ones, and in higher paying disciplines like engineering rather than comparative literature, and here's the other thing that I found surprising. It didn't matter whether the professor herself was a woman or a man. It was across the board. I find this so interesting, Dan, because of course there's all this other work that suggests that these unconscious biases that the professors had are really held by everyone. And I think studies like this suggest that we all need to be aware of how these biases operate in our lives. Absolutely. Shankar, let's see what you have. Your one minute starts right now. There's been a lot of debate in this country about test scores.
但有趣的是这种情况实际上在私立机构比公立机构更容易发生，而且在工程学等高薪学科中比在比较文学中更常见，还有一件事让我感到意外。教授本人是女性还是男性并不重要。这种现象普遍存在。丹，我觉得这太有趣了，因为当然还有许多其他研究表明，教授们拥有的这些无意识偏见其实每个人都有。我认为像这样的研究表明，我们所有人都需要意识到这些偏见是如何在我们的生活中运作的。当然。尚卡尔，来看看你有什么。你的一分钟现在开始。这个国家关于考试分数有很多争论。
If you can get teachers who boost the test scores of students, does this really tell you anything meaningful about the long term prospects of students, or are these merely teachers who know how to teach to the test? In a recent analysis of more than a million children in a large urban school district, the researchers Rod Chetty and John Friedman at Harvard and Jonah Rockoff at Columbia University find the answer is yes, it makes a huge difference. Chetty and his colleagues find that teachers who have a good track record of improving student test scores have long term effects on those student's lies.
如果你能找到那些能提高学生考试成绩的老师，这真的能说明任何关于学生长期前景的有意义的事情吗？或者这些仅仅是那些懂得如何应试教学的老师？在对一个大型城市学区的一百多万名儿童进行的一recent分析中，哈佛大学的罗德·切蒂（Raj Chetty）和约翰·弗里德曼（John Friedman）以及哥伦比亚大学的乔纳·罗科夫（Jonah Rockoff）发现，答案是肯定的，这会产生巨大的影响。切蒂和他的同事发现，那些在提高学生考试成绩方面有着良好记录的老师，会对这些学生的生命产生长期的影响。
The students are significantly more likely to attend college, to earn more money as young adults, and to live in better neighborhoods. The difference between having a mediocre teacher and one of the better teachers is actually enormous. Chedi and his colleagues find that having such a teacher can change your lifetime earnings by $39,000. And here's the part that's amazing about that statistic, Dan. This is the effect of having one great teacher in one grade in school, one grade, one teacher,
这些学生上大学的可能性显著增加，作为年轻人能赚到更多的钱，并且生活在更好的社区里。拥有一个平庸的老师和一个优秀的老师之间的差距其实是巨大的。切蒂和他的同事发现，拥有这样一位老师可以将你的终生收入改变39,000美元。丹，关于这个统计数据，最惊人的部分在这里。这仅仅是在学校里某一个年级拥有一位伟大的老师所产生的影响，一个年级，一位老师，
$39,000. Think about the effect of having several great teachers throughout your schooling years. Well, that's something we've always intuitive, but now there's some pretty good data to back that up. I agree, Dad. So let's get to your second study. Your next 60 seconds starts right now. We've talked about students and teachers. Let's bring a third party into the conversation. Parents. Oh, we know that parents matter. How can we get parents to matter more? Great study out of Brown and Harvard about a summer program where kids who had failed courses were trying to get credits so they could pass. The researchers organized the parents into three groups.
39,000美元。想想你在整个求学过程中遇到几位伟大的老师会产生什么影响。好吧，这是我们一直凭直觉能感受到的，但现在有一些相当不错的数据来支持这一点。我同意，丹。那么我们进入你的第二项研究。你的下一个60秒现在开始。我们讨论了学生和老师。让我们把第三方引入对话中。家长。哦，我们知道家长很重要。我们怎样才能让家长变得更重要呢？布朗大学和哈佛大学做了一项出色的研究，关于一个暑期项目，那些不及格的孩子正在努力获得学分以便能够及格。研究人员将家长分成三组。
One group was a control group, nothing happened to them. One group of parents got a weekly email or text message that had positive information about their student. John was an active participant in class all week, good job. The other third of parents got what was called an improvement message. So Tina missed two homework assignments this week. I know she can do better. Now of the families who got messages, those kids did dramatically better. They were 41% less likely to fail again. Wow. And what was really interesting is that the messages about improvement were far more effective than the messages that just conveyed
一组是对照组，什么都没做。第二组家长每周收到一封电子邮件或短信，里面包含关于他们学生的积极信息。“约翰这周在课堂上一直很积极参与，干得好。”剩下的三分之一家长收到了所谓的“改进信息”。所以，“蒂娜这周漏掉了两次家庭作业。我知道她能做得更好。”现在，在那些收到消息的家庭中，这些孩子的表现显著变好。他们再次不及格的可能性降低了41%。哇。而且真正有趣的是，关于改进的信息比仅仅传达
positive information. Wow, that's really interesting, Dan. The idea, of course, that positive affirmation can make a big difference to people has been shown in so many other fields as well. Yeah, I think the other thing that's cool about this is that this is an incredibly, incredibly cheap intervention. A text message every week, not a parent-teacher conference, not any kind of big intervention. And I think what it shows is that if we really want to improve the education system, there are some light touch, small wins that we can get that make a huge difference. I love it, Dan.
积极信息的消息要有效得多。哇，这真的很有趣，丹。当然，积极的肯定可以对人们产生重大影响这一观点，在许多其他领域也得到了证实。是的，我认为这件事酷的另一个地方在于，这是一项成本极其极其低廉的干预措施。每周发一条短信，而不是开家长会，也不是任何大型干预。我认为它表明，如果我们真的想改善教育体系，我们可以通过一些轻量级、低成本的小举措取得巨大成效。太棒了，丹。
So let's go to your shanker. You've got one minute. It starts now. When you think about what teachers communicate to students, Dan, and classrooms, we often think about facts, and theories, and explanation. We think about information. But some of the most important things that teachers communicate to students actually happens unconsciously. It's the expectations that a teacher communicates
那么轮到你了，尚卡尔。你有一分钟时间。现在开始。丹，当你想到老师在课堂上传达给学生的信息时，我们通常会想到事实、理论和解释。我们想到的是信息。但老师传达给学生的一些最重要的东西实际上是在无意识中发生的。那是老师传达的关于
about whether a student is going to succeed. And now these expectations are enormously powerful in shaping not just how the student behaves, but how the teacher then interacts with the student. In a study of elementary school eight children in Michigan was published in Merrill Palmer Quarterly in 2014, Jacqueline Eccles and Katja Opadjaya find that teachers' beliefs about the potential of children was a very
学生是否会成功的期望。现在，这些期望在塑造不仅是学生的行为方式，还有老师随后与学生的互动方式方面具有巨大的威力。在2014年发表在《梅里尔-帕尔默季刊》（Merrill-Palmer Quarterly）上的一项针对密歇根州小学8名儿童的研究中，杰奎琳·埃克尔斯（Jacqueline Eccles）和卡佳·奥帕贾亚（Katja Opijaya）发现，老师对儿童潜力的信念是预测儿童在整个小学期间数学考试成绩的非常
strong predictor of the children's math test scores throughout elementary school. Now obviously some of the teachers' beliefs are undoubtedly shaped by how these children are actually performing in the classroom, so beliefs don't just come out of thin air, but the insidious thing about this study and other studies, Dan, is that teachers' beliefs and students' behavior are a chicken and egg kind of thing. It isn't just the children's behavior that shapes the beliefs of their teachers, as we saw in the research by Hunter Gelbach, the beliefs of the teachers also shapes the behavior of the children. Go in with high expectations, you'll probably get good results.
强的指标。显而易见，老师的一些信念无疑是由这些孩子在课堂上的实际表现塑造的，所以信念并非凭空产生，但这项研究和其他研究的险恶之处在于，丹，老师的信念和学生的行为是一种鸡生蛋还是蛋生鸡的关系。正如我们在亨特·格尔巴赫的研究中所看到的，不仅是孩子的行为塑造了老师的信念，老师的信念也塑造了孩子的行为。抱着高期望进去，你可能会得到好的结果。
That's exactly right, Dan. This has been another edition of Stop What Science. I'm Shankar Vitaanthan. And I'm Daniel Pink. For more Hidden Brain, join us on Facebook and Twitter and listen to my NPR stories on your local public radio station. The Hidden Brain is produced by Karam Agargaleson and Maggie Pennman, special thanks this week to Anne Goodenkoff, our actor's Parker and Justin Reinhardt and their older sister,
完全正确，丹。这是又一期的“秒表科学”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我是丹尼尔·平克。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook和Twitter上加入我们，并在你当地的公共广播电台收听我的NPR故事。《隐藏的大脑》由卡拉姆·阿加加莱森（Karam Agargaleson）和玛吉·彭曼（Maggie Pennman）制作，本周特别感谢安·古登科夫（Anne Goodenkoff）、我们的演员帕克（Parker）和贾斯汀·莱因哈特（Justin Reinhardt）以及他们的姐姐、
Mia Reinhardt, who came along to help. I'm Shankar Vidantantham and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
前来帮忙的米娅·莱因哈特（Mia Reinhardt）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。